time for a good meal before heading to
the Mobile World Congress in Barcelona
physique Friedkin's man and his
colleague this is the first visit to an
authentic tapas bar it is also their
debut at the trade fair koontz minh is
hoping for global success with this
software which recognises different
languages writes them down and
translates them as a venture company
might only be small but we are hoping to
establish your reach similar to that of
whatsapp and we are working very hard
towards that we are improving our
technology and expanding our repertoire
of languages with the aim of eventually
being able to cover large parts of it if
not the entire world like Bob people
could big ambitions for a small start-up
but the product is quite simple
alright let's see or listen to what
happens with the help of another German
company at the trade fair he gives a
language recognition demonstration i'm
now leaving you a voice message and i'm
curious to see what the text looks like
and we could also meet tomorrow morning
thank you thumping in seconds later the
text appears it works in different
languages and even different dialects
but this English there's english chinese
english spanish english New York English
who you are Angus the tester is
impressed it's tailored for near the
mishima so I can call someone who speaks
a different language let's say Spanish
his text is transmitted translated into
German and then played to me as audio
for you if that can be done very quickly
in real time I can easily communicate
with people who speak different
languages languages I don't understand
refresh their state-of-the-art
technology from Germany could be
interesting for big companies in the
social media sector kunzelman whose
companies the only German one offering
voice recognition here sets off to find
the Facebook stand
there are no important social media
companies based in Europe so if it is
global recognition he wants he'll have
to deal with us companies I am looking
for facebook yeah bad only with an
appointment but he needs an appointment
to get to be seen so ops instead to go
and listen to facebook founder mark
zuckerberg talking live George
Zuckerberg talk here to he's not allowed
in he has the wrong path ok ja Kunz man
would have liked to hear the man who for
the past few months has been buying one
startup after another but at least the
talk is being broadcast on screens
around the venue the German businessman
is not looking to sell his company but
he would like to work with facebook
Facebook could be a partner for us and
we could prove our German technology
could be based in conjunction with a
market leader the Veil Falls Laura I did
follow Kunz man believes in his product
now all he needs is a suitable partner
in order to establish his technology on
the world market
you